Chris Pratt and Rob Lowe take off their
shirts while Katherine Schwarzenegger
slips into a red bikini during a day in
the California Sun and would you check
out those ABS yeah we're in the
honeymoon phase it feels really good and
we just feel really happy the 55 year
old actor joined the newlyweds at the
beach in Santa Barbara on Saturday where
he was spotted playing around on a
paddleboard while Chris and Catherine
glided through the ocean in a double
kayak from the swanky Miramar Club which
is located in the affluent town of
Montecito
Oprah's hometown Wow earlier in the day
Chris and Rob went golfing with Rob son
Johnny and it seems someone forgot the
sunscreen on Monday Chris instagrammed
this photo comparing his shorts and tan
line her burn to a delicious firecracker
popsicle it's a good time we're all very
blessed I feel good man that was Chris
chatting with et at the Avengers end
game premiere back in April just two
months before he and Catherine tied the
knot in a dreamy wedding in once again
Montecito a source previously told et
that Catherine knew the location and
showed Chris and he fell in love with it
too as for the details of their big day
our source says that Catherine smiled so
sweetly through the vows and at the
reception
she laughed non-stop according to the
source Chris and Catherine know this all
happened so fast but they're adamant it
just feels right
of course Lowe attended the couple's
nuptials where our source says he and
Catherine's brother Patrick were
chatting about how happy they were for
the newlyweds good things happening for
me in life I just count my blessings
every day
you
[Music]
[Applause]